[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show I
want to briefly talk a little bit about
masks and antibodies and immunity of the
story is that Senator Rand Paul who you
might remember had coronavirus and has
now recovered from it he was asked why
aren't you wearing a mask and he says he
doesn't need to because he has immunity
since he has already recovered from
coronavirus saying quote I've already
had the virus so I can't get it again
and I can't give it to anybody now
there's a couple of different things
here that need to be considered and I
want to make sure that we're kind of
doing it all thoroughly thoroughly one
is do antibodies confer immunity the
official statement is there is not yet
definitive evidence of that but it's
really important to understand that that
doesn't mean that it doesn't okay
typically with this type of virus once
you fight it off and fully generate
antibodies you cannot get infected again
now there are some caveats there which
is a very rapidly mutating virus you
would be able to reinfect you it's not
really a reinfection in the sense that
it's a different version of that virus
it's changed enough that the body sees
it as a different virus not exactly the
same one but I think one thing that has
been confusing to people PAP is we hear
there's no evidence that people are
immune once they've had it what what it
means is there's no definitive evidence
yet but if this virus is anything like
the other ones that are of this family
then you are immune the question is for
how long
yeah with other corona viruses you get
the virus you recover from it you have
the immunity you're not gonna get the
virus again we just don't know if that's
the case for this specific corona virus
because of course it's a novel
coronavirus it's so new we just haven't
studied it thoroughly and that's why I
think if even if you had the virus
before you should take every precaution
necessary you should still wear the mask
you should still behave as though you
can get the virus
because you don't want to get it again
you don't want to spread it to other
people and I think Rand Paul above
everyone else should know that by now
now there's one other component to this
which is Rand Paul says because he's
immune he can't spread it anymore that
is true in one sense and not true in
another and what I mean by that is
Donald Donald Trump Rand Paul cannot be
if the immunity is as we believe that it
should be Rand Paul can't be infected
again but he can still have the virus
physically on him and conceivably he
could cough it or sneeze it onto someone
so you could imagine a situation where
Rand Paul gets the viral cells into his
body again and they are in his throat
and then he sneezes on to someone and
passes those viral cells to another
person he won't be infected with the
virus necessarily but the physical
movement of the viral cells can still
happen and I think that that's another
thing that people are missing here yeah
and maybe Rand Paul is right maybe he
can't get the virus again or give it to
anyone else again but it's such a simple
thing to do to wear a mask especially
when everyone else is doing it wouldn't
you want to just do it for the sake of
solidarity and for the fact that you
know like the when he got the virus he
was acting as if everything was normal
you're still going to the gym and using
all his set of facilities and then so
that create a bunch of chaos when they
found out that he was positive for the
corona virus and had to clean everything
and they were worried about other
lawmakers also getting the disease
because he had to go through that
embarrassment wouldn't that lead you to
believe that he wants to be on people's
good side now and he would just kind of
wear the mask and behave now like why
wouldn't he do that very very basic
thing it continues to strike me as just
optics just thinking about optics and he
doesn't want to wear the mask he doesn't
want to be seen wearing the mask he
maybe want to downplay the seriousness
of the virus altogether and as we've
talked about when it comes to Donald
Trump and Mike Pence on the mask stuff
the management by optics is not is not
good now in terms of the protective
antibodies and the tests for antibodies
I was going to go and get an antibody
test this week quest now offers it you
just sign up online it's not free you
have to pay and then you set up an
appointment and you go and you get
tested only a couple antibody tests
right now have been FDA approved all of
the other ones the companies have to
self certify if you can imagine
something so
earlier than that and quest is one of
those now the administration has come
out or the FDA has said in the next 10
days they can't just self certify they
need to actually demonstrate the
accuracy of the antibody test so I've
decided I'm gonna wait maybe late next
week we would have a more reliable
antibody test and then I would go and
get one and report back to everybody
okay so let's say you get the antibody
test next week and you test positive
which means yeah you had the virus at
one point maybe it was when you had that
cough back in February sure that you're
concerned about will that change your
behavior at all will you no longer wear
the mask will you no longer observe the
social distancing measures like how will
that affect your day-to-day in the
immediate it won't affect my day-to-day
at all but I do think that it's if if we
get a determination that the antibodies
are definitely protective there could be
a time during the reopening period where
it would impact what I do and and it
wouldn't encourage risky behavior but
imagine that on May 18th Massachusetts
can start to open some things and we
determined that I have antibodies and
they are protective maybe I'm more
willing to go sit in a cafe for 90
minutes and work on stuff I mean I don't
know again I don't want to pretend like
I'm going to be going around doing what
Rand Paul is doing saying I'm now immune
and but I think it I always want more
information and it's a piece of
information that would be a relevant one
to have I think yeah we just want to be
cautious though because we don't have
all the facts yet naturally and it would
be great to know and to find out
conclusively that if you get the corona
virus once and you have the antibodies
you can't get it again because that
would mean that maybe we can reopen
earlier and you know that would make our
sort of like strategy for getting the
country back up and running a little bit
smoother right because you wouldn't have
to worry about reinfection so hopefully
this is the case where it's a one and
done thing but before we know
conclusively everyone has to be cautious
and just one other reminder all of the
stories so far about supposedly
infections have been debunked there's
been the South Korea story about
reinfection that has been determined to
have been people who had not yet
actually shed the virus complete had not
stopped shedding virus completely but
had a false negative at a certain point
or
tests that were not accurate there is no
actual evidence of reinfection right now
I think I want to make sure we're not
spreading some of the disinformation
that is out there we are still waiting
for conclusive evidence of immunity
after you have had the virus and maybe
at some point an indication of how long
what one might be immune although we
don't yet know for sure okay one of the
things that has been talked about a
little bit is this idea of there are
cost to staying closed too long now when
Trump says it it's completely flippant
and it's this calculation of let him die
and it's absolutely disgusting and we're
against it and it's not being seriously
managed by Donald Trump because he
doesn't really seem to understand stuff
however the UN's humanitarian chief has
said that we need global cooperation and
financial assistance to prevent the
coronavirus closures from causing hunger
deaths and hunger related disease which
could double because of the economic
situation and hunger is a big problem in
the world we know that mathematically
more than enough food for everybody is
produced but that between the amount of
food that never makes it to supermarkets
the amount of food that's thrown out the
amount of food that people buy but then
throw into the trap because of a
distribution issue hunger is a real
problem on this planet and the UN has
now said that there is expected to be a
large increase in the number of people
that are going to be literally starving
to death or having hunger related
diseases and this partially relates to
some of the supply of food being
affected by coronavirus although that is
actually not the biggest concern the
biggest concern is more the distribution
piece and aid countries both reducing
aid as they have to focus internally
during the corona virus as well as just
logistical stuff fewer aid flights that
are going around so on and so forth so
it is true that coronavirus could have
the follow-on effects of increasing
hunger for
but not for the reason people like Trump
believe it's because of its because of
the bigger picture of what's going on
yeah but regardless you're going to need
four and eight to solve the crisis right
to mitigate the harm that can take place
over the next few months and I worry
that countries like the United States
that are becoming more nationalist you
know we hear this like america-first
sentiment that we're not gonna be
willing to pay up that money especially
when there's like this anti United
Nations sentiment right now with what's
going on with the World Health
Organization and how Trump continues to
attack them if you willing to take five
hundred billion five hundred million
dollars away from the World Health
Organization's budget I think you would
also be willing to not contribute to
funds that go towards feeding people and
that's a concern because I don't think
other countries can do it without the
help of the United States there is no
question that Trump would
temperamentally be predisposed to say
hey you know what we've got big problems
right now the one thing that might keep
him from doing that is his narrative is
we don't really have that big of a
problem right like as crazy as it is
Trump's insistence that were past the
peak and things are improving and we're
ready to open up again optics management
management by optics
if Trump wants to continue acting like
things are fine then it wouldn't be
coherent to say things are also not fine
to such a degree that we can't keep
sending rice to Africa that would
reminds me of that meme you know with a
dog sitting down at a table and the room
is burning around him and he says this
is fine that's exactly what's going on
here where Trump is trying to paint a
different picture than what reality is
and unfortunately that many of his
followers go along with it unless I
guess they're more personally impacted
by the virus or by the economic collapse
they're still believing that you know
Trump is right to start reopening that
where the worst is over that you know we
weren't hit here in the US as badly as
we could have been or you know as badly
as other countries were so there
definitely is a disconnect there let's
talk about the future of progressive
activism a little bit there's a group
called Justice Democrats which is a
left-wing group that would endorse and
support candidates who adopted a certain
platform and they would support them and
endorse them at the local level and
there are also
national candidates in the House and
Senate that said it actually I'm less
sure but certainly in the house do you
know Pat has justice Democrats endorse
Senate candidates I don't know if they
have endorse Senate candidates or if
they've like you know sort of expose the
public to Santa Kennedy is for the first
time and those Senate candidates went on
to win whereas they have done that with
the house I don't know though in any
case the Justice Democrats have now
formed a pact and this is creating a lot
of turmoil within some on the left
because you have a group that liked
justice Democrats because one of the
characteristics one of the policy
platforms of the people endorsed by
justice Democrats is that they would not
accept corporate money as an example and
at the same time forming a PAC seems to
run counter to the position on campaign
finance that the Justice Democrats were
espousing I'm gonna be totally honest
with you pat I really don't care about
this in a sense that like I care about
it as a story but I don't care about
justice Democrats in the sense that for
me I have never really loved the idea of
these organizations that sort of give a
stamp of approval to candidates I'm okay
with something like the NRA grades
people you know and then we hey if
you've got an F from the NRA that's
interesting to me I oh you're probably
doing something right and I want to look
at that or you know of pro-choice groups
would say these are the strongest
pro-choice can okay that's but an actual
group that says here are the candidates
to support in this race that race the
other one I don't know that they're
doing anything wrong I don't have I
don't think believe it but for me it's
never been an appealing way to think
about who I want to support so with the
single issue endorsements you're okay
with that but when it comes down to a
group like justice Democrats who expects
like five or six different policy
positions from their candidates does
that get to be too much for you to say
that it's not about the number of issues
for me it's listen if you if you are a
group that does something else like okay
Planned Parenthood does stuff right
Planned Parenthood does stuff they fund
family planning okay and then they also
can have a
position as to which candidates would be
best or worse for what their mission is
and if I like Planned Parenthood I can
look at that and it would form a piece
of what I do justice Democrats is just a
group to pick candidates and get him
elected and that is what I am less into
for me personally I'm not again I'm not
saying they shouldn't exist or they
don't doing anything wrong
but for me it's never been an
interesting way to think about who I
want to support is the point that I'm
making that's interesting I'm more
apathetic to it I feel as if you know at
this point progressives have gone
through so many losses it would just be
great to win you know and if winning
means that we have this group like
justice Democrats who are promoting all
these candidates right and you know
there's this like insurgents of new
younger progressive candidates who enter
into the House and Senate and it's all a
credit to justice Democrats then I'm all
for that if they do it organically
without any sort of group I'm okay with
that too and that's why in the same way
with this like this super PAC position
there seems to be like two different
things going against each other one is
this principle that we don't want to
take big money and we don't want to be
owned and operated by you know big banks
and defense contractors and health
insurance companies and the types of
things that usually go along with that
big money and this idea that we want to
win like those two things are competing
for me right now I feel like winning is
more important and then you can deal
with the campaign finance structure once
you get in the it's a power if you want
it then pass an amendment to get rid of
money in politics if you want to get the
courts to overturn citizens united or do
however you know whatever you want when
it comes to that once you have power I
think that at this point seems to be the
way to go I'm completely on board with
you about I just want to win and so to
the extent that justice Democrats is
winning it all power to them my point is
I don't I think we actually have the
same point which is I don't care that
they formed a PAC like I'm fine with the
PAC and I was fine but it's not really a
big deal to me either way and I think
you're sort of saying the same thing
which is PAC or not you want to get
people in who are then going to actually
make change I'm right there with you
what I'm pointing out is I don't really
care that much whether they do or don't
have a PAC okay that makes sense yeah I
mean I wish they could do it without the
PAC I wish they could be just as
successful without it it just seems as
if with our current campaign finance
structure you kind of have to go along
to get along
to compete on a level playing field and
it seems as though we've tried this
experiment a couple times before do you
lit the unilateral disarmament thing
just isn't working I mean we Bernie
Sanders lost twice and progressives
don't have that much say in American
politics right now so if something is
working it as strategy is failing you
want to change course a little bit well
that is exactly a lot of supporters of
Justice Democrats disagree with justice
Democrats has a lot of supporters that
are furious about this because they're
saying the talking point for lack of a
better term that Pat just used about
unilateral disarmament they say some of
them say that is a centrist corporatist
talking point meant not actually to
create progressive change and that's
exactly I agree with you Pat but there's
a lot of people that that's exactly why
they're mad they don't agree with you
yeah I mean I feel like a lot of
supporters of Justice Democrats were
against the pact thing because they
didn't want to be seen as hypocrites
right because you can't say that you're
against money in politics and all this
corporate influence on our
representatives and then form a pack of
your own that just that's a
contradiction it's sort of inherently I
guess you can explain it away with this
like secondary thing that I mentioned
which is once you get in power then you
upend the system but they understand how
you want to act on principle and you
don't want to play the game that
Republicans are playing the problem is
the Republicans are winning and they
continue to win and you know even if
it's not Republicans it's the centrist
Democrats who justices Democrats are
also opposed to so if you want to win
and you see what the other side is doing
and they seem to be pulling it off you
kind of got to play ball that's my
position right now because I'm sick of
losing one other thing some of the wins
that it looks like we may get in the
Senate in November if things go right
none of them are candidates that justice
Democrats would be okay with and I think
none that I'm aware of maybe there is
someone somewhere but the prominent ones
like Mark Kelly Sarah Gideon Steve
Bullock these are folks that would be
too conservative for justice Democrats
and I think it's important to also point
out if we get some of those wins those
are folks who if it were up to this
group would not even be the candidates
and I think that that's a relevant thing
when we think about if we want to
prioritize winning we
need to be thinking about that
inconsiderate cap let me know what you
think that is it for today we'll have a
new show and a new bonus show for you
tomorrow
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]